glv yeux adore l'application onstar de
gm il peut déverrouiller les portes de
sa cadillac escalade la démarrer et là
géolocalisé en tout temps l'été dernier
il décide de vendre sa cadillac et
oublie l'application manger parce que
rendu concessionnaires que l'application
arrêt
aurait débarqué par curiosité il appuie
sur l'icône l'appli est toujours active
maintenant j'ai cliqué leur super héros
j'ai retrouvé le véhicule dans lequel
ils s'en allaient se revoir l'autoroute
nous élections où la dose lui c'est
quand même très troublant la titulaire
de la chaire de recherche sur
l'intelligence artificielle responsable
à l'université d'ottawa il voit une
importante brèche de sécurité qui peut
entraîner de graves conséquences les
menaces physiques ou ddm des menaces de
dévoiler des informations personnelles
du harcèlement nous partons à saint
louis dans le missouri à la rencontre du
nouveau propriétaire qui ne sait pas que
sa vie privée est compromise à la hausse
nous proposons de faire une
démonstration
general motors a refusé notre demande
d'entrevue mais nous écrit qu'elle a
mise en place des procédures en cas de
vente ou de transfert garantissant qu'un
client avertir à gm une procédure dictée
dans les conditions d'utilisation de
l'apli en star c'est un peu facile de la
part des entreprises aidées des vendeurs
de se déresponsabiliser finalement sur
la tête du consommateur
m ne fait pas bon d'avoir d'autres
fabricants automobiles exige des
conditions d'utilisation similaires et
demande aux clients de les prévenir dès
qu'il ya un changement de propriétaire
une pratique aujourd'hui remise en
question ici annie husson fressoz radio
canada montréal